current rate of date the current number
of daily infections are around 200 000
while omicron represents over 20 percent
of cases in england we've already seen
it rise to over 44
in london
and we expect it to become the dominant
covert 19 variant in the capital in the
next 48 hours
there are currently 10 confirmed people
in england who have been hospitalized
with omicron
it's vital we remember that
hospitalizations and deaths lag
infections by around two weeks
so we can expect those numbers to
dramatically increase in the days and
weeks that lie ahead
in preparation the uk's four chief
medical officers raised the covered
alert level to four
its second highest level this was done
over the weekend
and nhs england has just announced that
it will return to its highest level of
emergency preparedness level 4 national
incident
this means the nhs response to omicon
will be coordinated as a national effort
rather than led by individual trusts
the second thing that we've learned in
the past week mr speaker is that two
jabs are not enough to prevent
symptomatic infection from omicron
but a third dosed a booster dose
provides strong protection with analysis
by the uk health security agency showing
a third dose is 70 percent effective at
preventing symptomatic infection
and we expect the booster to take effect
more quickly than the second
dose we're already running the most
successful booster campaign in europe
over 4 in 10 uk adults have now received
a third dose or booster
and saturday was a record with over half
a million boosters given across the uk
but mr speaker
with the race between the virus and the
vaccine so close
we must move faster
two weeks ago we announced that we would
offer every eligible adult a booster by
the end of january
but in response to the omicron emergency
and as the prime minister announced
yesterday evening
we're bringing that target forward by a
month and launching the omicron
emergency boost
we've opened the booster program to
every adult who's had a second dose of
the vaccine at least three months ago to
offer them the chance of getting their
booster before the new year
so from this morning
anyone over 18 can walk into a
vaccination center
and from wednesday they can book online
via the nhs website
the uk government will also provide
whatever support is needed to accelerate
vaccinations in scotland wales and
northern ireland
we have the jobs the challenge now that
we have the jabs the challenge now is to
get them into the arms
to meet our ambitious target the nhs
will need to deliver a record number of
jabs
until now the highest number of jabs
that we've delivered in a single day in
the uk was over eight hundred and forty
thousand
we'll now will not only need to match
that but we will need to beat that every
day
but we can
and we've got a plan to try and do it
we're opening more vaccination sites
including pop-up and mobile sites
that'll be working seven days a week
we're training thousands more volunteer
vaccinators we're asking gps and
pharmacies to do more
and we're drafting in 42 military
planning teams across every region of
our country
mr speaker this collective national
mission will only succeed if we all play
our part
those who haven't had their booster
should find their local walk-in and
vaccination center or they can book an
appointment in the on the nhs website
from wednesday
those who have had their booster jab
should encourage their friends and
family to do the same
those who have or have recently had
covid should wait 28 days from their
positive result to get their booster
and
to those who haven't had their vaccine
at all yet mr speaker
i would like to say this
whatever has held you back in the past
please think again and book your job as
quickly as possible
by acting together to get boosted now we
can protect ourselves against omicron
this winter
mr speaker
i acknowledge that our national mission
comes with some difficult trade-offs
we are redeploying nhs staff away from
non-urgent services
this means that
for the next two weeks
all primary care services will focus on
urgent clinical needs and vaccines
and some urgent appointments in elective
surgeries may be postponed until the new
year while we prioritize getting people
the booster
these are steps that no health secretary
would wish to take unless they were
absolutely necessary
but i'm convinced that if we don't
prioritize the booster now the health
consequences will be far more grave in
the months that lie ahead
mr speaker
our omicron emergency boost is a major
step
but i'm not going to pretend that this
alone will be enough to see us through
the difficult weeks
ahead because of the threat of omicron
we are moving to plan b in england
subject to the will of this house
meaning that we must use face coverings
in indoor public places
people should work from home if they can
and from wednesday again subject to this
house
you'll need to show a nagger a negative
lateral flow test to get into nightclubs
and large events with an exemption for
the double vaccinated
once all adults have had a reasonable
chance to get their booster jab we
intend to change this exemption to
require a booster dose
even with plan b mr speaker
we still have far fewer restrictions in
place than europe
i can also confirm mr speaker that from
tomorrow
fully vaccinated contacts of a covert 19
case will now be able to take a daily
lateral flow test instead of
self-isolating this is a vital way to
minimize the disruption to people's
daily lives and to avoid the so-called
pandemic
and i can assure this house that the uk
has sufficient lateral flow test to see
us through the coming weeks
if anyone finds that they are unable to
get a kit online they should check the
website the following day or they can
pop down to their local pharmacy and
pick up a kid
and from today i can confirm that the
nhs covet pass is being rolled out to 12
and 15 year olds for international
travel
allowing even more people to be able to
prove their vaccine status for travel
where it is needed
from today
mr speaker
mr speaker
taken together these are proportionate
balance steps keeping the country moving
while slowing the spread of omicron and
buying us more time to get more boosters
into arms
we're also taking steps to keep people
safe in adult social care
and we know that sadly
people in care homes and those who
receive domiciliary care are more likely
to suffer serious health consequences if
they get covered 19.
so we're expanding our specialist
vaccination teams to get more boosters
to the vulnerable and those providing
care
beneath but even as we do so
we must go further to protect colleagues
and residents from omicron
so we are increasing the frequency of
staff testing
and
with a heavy heart we must restrict
every resident to just three nominated
visitors not including their essential
caregiver
this is a difficult step
and i understand that it comes with an
impact on physical and mental well-being
but we know that from previous waves
that it's one of the most effective
things that we can do to protect
vulnerable residents
we are also increasing our workforce
recruitment and retention fund with 300
million pounds of new money this is an
addition to the
162.5 million pounds we announced in
october
the funds will help pay bonuses bring
forward pay rises and forget for the
care staff and fund overtime and
increase workforce numbers over the
winter
mr speaker i know that honorable members
had hoped that the days of this kind of
covid19 update were behind us
after our successful reopening this
summer it is not an update that i wanted
to deliver
but the renewed threat of omicron means
that we've got more work to do to stay
ahead of this virus
we can if we all play our part and
boosters are the key we've achieved so
many phenomenal things over the last two
years
and i know we are weary
but it's on all of us to pick up to step
up and do some phenomenal work once
again to play our part and to get
boosted now i commend this statement to
the house
can i suggest the secretary of state we
could be a pop-up site for all the staff
that work here to get them boosted can i
now come to the shadow of secretary of
state west greeting
thank you mr speaker and can i thank the
secretary of state for advanced site of
his statement
today mr speaker we learned of the first
death
in the uk as a result of the omicron
virus so on behalf of the whole house
can i send our condolences to the
friends and family of that person who's
lost their life
their death sends this statement sets
this statement and the task at hand in
context it is a stark reminder that the
pandemic is not over that the new
variant is a clear and serious risk to
our public health
and of the urgency of getting britain
boosted and protecting us against this
threat
mr speaker the labour party will always
act in the best interests of our nhs of
our public health and of our nation
having repeatedly called for the booster
program to be ramped up we will give our
full support to this effort and we on
these benches will make every effort to
get the message out that vaccines are
the best tool we have at our disposal to
protect ourselves to protect those
closest to us and to protect our nhs
the target of getting one million people
a day their booster vaccine is
unprecedented and it may even prove
impossible but we applaud the ambition
if anyone can do it the nhs can and the
whole country will be willing them on
and will not knock them for trying what
people will not accept is the government
moving the goalposts the prime minister
is now famous for over-promising and
under-delivering
in his televised address last night he
said and i quote people will have the
chance to get the booster before the new
year
but that aim is instead as we've heard
from the secretary of state is to offer
the booster to every adult by the end of
the month meaning the delivery will wait
until january or even february
is the government now rowing back on the
target set yesterday if so why is it
changed overnight
and what hope do we have of achieving
the level of booster jabs we need if the
public and those delivering the vaccines
are told one thing one day and another
the next
the prime minister has got to learn to
be straight with people because he is
undermining public trust and confidence
in the government and public health
measures at a critical time
can i also ask what discussions the
secretary of state has had with local
authorities gps pharmacies and other
delivery partners who'll be crucial to
this effort then there is the shambles
of testing i must say mr speaker i
thought the secretary of state might be
living on a different planet when he
described the availability of testing
because the government's website today
states that home testing kits are
currently unavailable pharmacies across
the country are out of stock and even
here in parliament there are no home
testing kits available from portcullis
house
no doubt this is due to a surge in
demand ahead of the new testing
requirements this week but surely that
should have been foreseen
and this is a serious problem those
coming into contact with positive
omicron cases will not be able to follow
the rules and get themselves tested on a
daily basis those who require tests to
undertake home visits risk being left
short many others need them for work so
how does the secretary of state plan to
ensure there are enough tests in stock
and available to everyone who needs them
when they need them and when will this
be resolved it doesn't appear the
secretary of state was even aware of the
problem
absent from the prime minister's address
last night was any plan to speed up the
vaccine rollout for 12 to 15 year olds
on current trends some teenagers won't
receive their vaccine until february
five months after the government's
initial target of october half term
children have already faced significant
disruptions their education so will the
secretary of state update the house on
the vaccine rollout for 12 to 15 year
olds will they receive their vaccines by
the end of the christmas holidays as
we've called for and of course mr
speaker patients will be concerned by
the news that appointments will be
delayed to accommodate the booster
rollout there is no doubt
that the booster program is the right
priority if we don't get ahead of
omicron the pressure on the nhs will be
unbearable and the disruptions people's
avoid appointments in the eu in the new
year will be severe
but let's be honest mr speaker the
challenge is made so much greater as a
direct result of the government's
mismanagement of the nhs for 11 years we
went into the pandemic with record
waiting lists six-figure staff shortages
in the health service and the care
sector so where is the nhs workforce
plan where is the plan for recovery of
elective care and why can this
government not understand that their
continued failure to fix social care is
piling even more pressure on the nhs at
the worst possible time
and on social care visits mr speaker can
i ask the secretary of state to think
again about limits on care home visits
this feels like the wrong decision at
the wrong time
mr speaker i'd like to conclude if i can
with some words directed to the public
we realize on these benches the prime
minister has tested patience by asking
people to follow the rules when number
10 didn't
the prime minister's actions in recent
weeks have undermined trust at a
critical moment so i say to people
feeling let down or lied to that i do
trust the chief medical officer i do
trust the chief scientific advisor and i
do trust the nhs the prime minister
might not lead by example but the rest
of us can
and we the labour party trust you the
british people to do the right thing to
protect yourselves to protect the ones
you love and to protect the nhs
mr speaker first of all can i say i
heard your request at the start and if
it's okay with you mr speaker that's
something i'm happy to take up with you
uh directly and can i thank the
honourable gentleman uh for his uh
support of the the need to accelerate uh
the the booster program and and can i
also uh join him in i'm sure that has
the whole house does express condolences
uh for the individual uh that has uh
been the the first in this country uh to
die with uh this new variant uh omicron
um turning to the honourable gentleman's
uh questions
first the honourable gentleman has uh
asked about uh the um
the testing uh capacity and uh and i
would actually
like to be uh to share more information
with the house there is no shortage of
actual tests that are held by uk hsa
there are millions tens of millions of
tests to stop millions arriving each
week the issue the limiting factor
because of the hugely increased demand
and i'm sure members can understand why
demand has suddenly surged is the
ability to deliver uh the tests and
having enough capability to deliver the
tests
because the current arrangements with
royal mail alone are not enough there
are new arrangements that are reached
with amazon and other
delivery methods and and what that means
there will still be many hundred
thousand record number delivered each
day but also the number of access points
is being increased including many more
through pharmacies and rapidly looking
at other access points i think the
objective is right to raise this but i
hope he and other members understand
there's been a huge surge in increase
and it's not just about the number of
tests that available it's about getting
them through and delivered both uh
equally uh uh important um the the the
other issue the honourable gentleman uh
raised uh was about the the booster
program itself and the timing of that
program and and he's right that just a
couple of weeks ago uh the the plan was
to get everyone a boost this was after
the change in advice from the jcvi to
reduce the dosing gap to three months
and their advice that it should include
now everyone over the age of 18. if the
plan was to do that by the end of
january for the reasons that i've
explained and the prime minister shared
in his national broadcast yesterday we
want to bring that forward and and what
this is is a working hard with the nhs
and the nhs by the way has done
absolutely phenomenal work all ready to
reach four in ten adults with boosters
and with their vaccination program in
general it is asking a huge amount of
our colleagues in the nhs
and and it is our joint view that we can
try to offer um
adults a chance to get boosted by the
end of this month and that does not mean
every single person necessarily can can
get that boost it requires them to come
forward and to take up this offer as
well as as well as everything going
right in this huge expansion plan but i
again i hope the
honorable gentleman can respect that the
nhs is doing everything it can with this
full support of every department of
government to throw everything at this
to offer as many uh opportunities and
the maximum possible capacity that there
is uh for uh delivering on that
commitment uh the the
honourable gentleman also uh asked about
the
talked about the nhs uh in terms of uh
the challenges that he's facing i would
like to remind him and the house that
this year the the government has put in
an extra 34 billion pounds into the nhs
and social care 5.4 billion pounds of
that in in the second half this year and
over the next three years there's a
commitment to at least eight billion
pounds extra into the largest catch-up
fund the nhs has ever seen in the last
year we've seen almost some ten thousand
nurses join the nhs almost three
thousand doctors the nhs is creating
workforce it's increasing capacity
it's looking at new ways to do electives
and it's putting a huge amount of effort
into its electives program and it's
non-coded work as well and then lastly
on adult social care and a limited
visitors i do understand what the
honourable gentleman has said and it is
uh important i think to get the balance
right here we all know uh the problems
that and the sad deaths that we saw in
care homes with this pandemic uh not
that long ago and it is right to take
balanced measures to to protect people
in care homes when working and listening
with those people that run our care
homes and to try to take a balanced
approach that allows visits to take
place but it also protects those
individuals that are so vulnerable
joe's select committee jeremy hill thank
you mr speaker one year and five days
ago the uk administered the first
properly approved covid vaccine in the
world and the government is absolutely
right to focus its strategy on
immunisation but israel approved booster
jabs for all adults in september france
approved jabs for teenagers in june both
long before us united states has already
approved jabs for five-year-olds again
long before us is he worried that our
regulators having been the nimblest in
the world are now taking too long they
are brilliant scientists they are
rightly totally independent but what can
he do to speed up this crucial
decision-making in a pandemic
mr speaker my my right-hand friend makes
a very important point with experience
and i i i think it's fair to say we can
be proud of so much of what our
regulators have achieved and what
they've done and
as he has said himself we were the first
in the world to approve uh a covid19 uh
vaccine but he's also right to challenge
on this and ask what more can be done
especially in light of the circumstances
we face i i hope my honourable gentleman
can also uh commend how jcvi since the
emergence of omicron and i know they're
not a regulator but they're an important
part of the approvals process
about how quickly they reacted in
changing the rules around boosters as
soon as we learned about omicron
we now come to snp spokesperson alan
brown
thank you mr speaker
it's worth putting the record scott is
the most vaccinated nation in the uk and
cellar would encourage aveda to continue
to take up um uptake of the booster
now does the secretary share my outrage
that his back ventures last week were
literally cheering the proposition that
he needs to wait until more people are
hospitalized before they'll countenance
awareness mass in public places is
absolutely reckless and it sends the
wrong message to the public and they're
trying to
tell them to take the rest of omicron
seriously now tragically we know people
are now being hospitalized and already
recorded sadly one death roman micron so
based on evidence elsewhere what kind of
upward trajectory does the secretary
think is going to be in terms of hostile
hospitalization
and why the plan b measures being
brought forward so already in place in
scotland as a republic sampson because
that makes no sense
now govern lfts are only 50 accurate
what risk implications as he assessed in
terms of using lfts to keep people from
self-isolating surely needs to consider
the minimum being a pcr test and follow
the more cautious approach being adopted
the scottish government and why when
lfts is their key guidance have they put
themselves in this ridiculous possession
of their website saying they've run out
lft cuts
and mr speaker if we're talking about
supporting people to self-isolate then
we really need to do a revisit
and extend the levels of statutory sec
pay and so what discussions is the
secretary having the chancellor in the
dwp sector about this
and critically does he support calls
from the devolved nations that they need
treasury support to put in place what
restrictions they believe are required
to control the spread and impact of
omicron and support livelihoods at the
same time the scottish governments were
ready to put in place a more generous
rates relief the hospitality earners
from the uk government did but with
trade dropping suppliers and the trade
itself need further support especially
further restrictions are required going
forward as well to take this up with the
chancellor and also as the cabinet
considering support for the travel
industry
agree that targeted sector restrictions
with full financial support is a better
long-term strategy rather than the
all-or-nothing type approach that we
seem to be and praying that the booster
program alone will be sufficient because
it's going to need a lot more work than
just that alone
mr speaker the honourable gentleman is
right to point to the lag between the
point of infection and hospitalizations
and that i think emphasizes the need to
act early and to act strongly and that's
why the booster program and that
response is so important in scotland in
england throughout the uk it is good
that all four nations are working very
closely together on that on the lateral
flow tests as a as a way uh alternative
to self-isolation i think lateral flow
tests are the right approach they can be
taken daily so that individual you know
is tested
each day for seven days where pcr is
will be a single test at a single moment
and i just think it's much more uh
flexible and it's something that's based
on advice that ministers have received
and in his questions around uh economic
support that's something we keep under
review
andrew lensen
thank you mr speaker i do congratulate
the government on the rollout of the
vaccination program it is impressive but
what does my right honourable friend say
to my constituent who says she is now
less afraid of covid than she is of
intrusive and incoherent government
regulations
i would say to my honorable friend that
i hope uh her constituent would
appreciate
that uh that we the government has to
act on the information that it sees
before it in terms of the spread of this
new variant the rate of spread uh the
information we now know about its degree
of vaccine escape not just to protect
her constituent but also to protect her
constituents loved ones and her
community
barry sherman
deputy speaker can i
say to the secretary of state i was
deeply shocked when he was in this house
recently and when i said all sensible
members of parliament will be supporting
any measure to save lives and i had
booze and cat calls from the government
benches can i repeat my view
that does he realize for a great
potential we as members of parliament in
our communities working for this rolling
our sleeves up working cross parties
with local councillors and local
volunteers this is a real resource this
house of commons please please when he
uses effectively yeah
mr deputy speaker can i thank the
honorable gentleman for his his call for
all members uh to do their bit to help
the nation at this time of crisis and
it's not just what we can all do in this
house but i'm sure he'll agree is what
we can do in our local communities
robert halfon
um thank you um mr deputy speaker my
right honourable friend rightly talks
about protecting the nhs but uh could i
ask him if he will ensure that we
protect our children as well
and make sure that the schools are kept
open in january that the government sets
out a plan for keeping the schools
open in january and given that the
sunday times
um suggested that primary school
children were going to be vaccinated
will my friend come in and make a
statement or the department of education
uh secretary of state make a statement
about this vaccination uh program for
children for younger children and ensure
that there is 100 parental consent
first of all mr deputy speaker can i
agree with my right honourable friend on
the importance of protecting our
children and we all know now in this
house that how house children have
suffered throughout through this
pandemic and the impact there's been on
them their education their mental health
uh their their social socialization with
other children and many others and he's
right to talk about that
importance and one of the reasons to
take the measures that we've said
especially around the expanding the
booster program is to make sure we can
prioritize our children on the issue of
uh vaccination for younger children for
five to eleven
that is something that the jcvi is
considering when we when the government
does hear back from the jcvi on that
that is something of course the
government will bring to the house
so george howard
thank you mr speaker the um can i
welcome the secretary of state's
statements and having listened to it and
studied the matter in some detail over
the weekend
i will be supporting the government
tomorrow night with the measures they're
introducing but
what would the secretary state have to
say
to those out there in the community who
are saying
if the government the rule makers can't
be
trusted to obey their own rules why
should we yeah
first mr deputy can i thank the older
gentleman for his uh support uh and i
think it's uh it's always important to
to emphasize that these rules whether
we're discussing now all rules uh of any
type really but obviously he's talking
about rules around the pandemic they are
there for all of us and they equally
apply to all of us
human
mr deputy speaker
gps particularly those in rural areas i
find it difficult and challenging to be
able to deliver the booster program
we'll have to deliver in great numbers
would the secretary of state look at
measures which will actually speed
through the flow
for those gp surgeries and we also send
the message out to all patients out
there that they will need to be
understanding over the next couple of
weeks and ensure that the morale of our
gps who work so hard is not
undermined
well first of all mr deputy speaker my
honourable friend is right to talk about
how hard gps have been working
throughout this uh pandemic but also
about the need to provide greater
support we expect them and would need
them to help with this big new
vaccination effort and
and i do think there are already signs
uh of of many people uh showing how they
understand the need for gps to
re-prioritize over the next couple of
weeks and that's important too john
spell
thank you mr deputy speaker it's clear
from the secretary of state statement
that he's a considerable improvement on
his predecessor so i'm sure he accepts
that kovid is now endemic and variants
will probably be returning for years if
not decades in that case surely by now
instead of the erratic response we've
seen we should have a well prepared plan
of action and chain of command ready to
be activated as soon as a new variant is
detected as well as enough supplies and
trained personnel to operate it so why
does his department seem to be
continually surprised by the arrival of
variants and instead of a smooth running
plan we have chaos and panic
well mr speaker the
there are going to be variants of of of
covert 19 as the olympian tournament
says for for many years and indeed there
have been many hundreds of variants and
there is no country in the world that is
better at surveillance of those variants
may i remind the honourable gentleman
that it was the uk that alerted the
world to the threat of omicron and there
is no country
that is better prepared if you look at
how how quickly and swiftly the uk
reacted for example with its
international restrictions the
information we shared with the world on
vaccine so uh i i i think uh the
honourable gentleman uh he understands
those uh points uh i regret the the way
he's uh framed his question
steve bryan
very much mr deputy and i think my
wrongful friendly statement many of my
constituents will be very surprised
indeed to hear from this morning anyone
over 18 can walk into a vaccination
center i wonder if he might give me an
update on on the hampshire situation but
could ask him about the nhs covered past
being rolled out to 12 to 15 year olds
which is such a welcome announcement and
something that secretary of state
promised this house that he'd bring back
and i thank him for that how exactly
will that work many of my constituents
will be traveling within the next few
days certainly within the next week over
christmas how exactly will they be able
to access this pass given that they
cannot access the nhs app the same way
as adults can
yeah i can thank my thanks my um
honorable friend for uh for what he said
and and he's right that this is a around
the covered past it's a it's a very
important issue we will be publishing uh
shortly on the website exactly how that
would work uh but it's being rolled out
as a digital past in the same way it's
working for adults uh starting today
toby perkins thank you
very much indeed mr deputy speaker the
prime minister addressed the nation
yesterday but what he hasn't done is
address the nhs in the same way when i
spoke at four o'clock to derbyshire they
were unaware of they had no system
letter from the department of health
around prioritization of vaccines they
were unaware about whether the quality
outcomes framework payments were
suspended they were unaware about the
winter access fund obligations they had
had now been suspended so can the
secretary of state inform make sure all
of our
health
providers are informed about these
crucial matters that actually give
reality in terms of their delivery of
these really important messages that
he's got in terms of the funding and the
priorities that there are for the
national health service
secretary
yes mr deputy speaker the honourable
gentleman will appreciate it's a very
fast-moving situation the nhs
made the final decision to go on the
expansion this expansion and the booster
program that i referred to earlier
yesterday and the system letter has gone
out today
ian duncan smith uh mr deputy speaker
can i say to my right-hand friend that
it's welcome that he comes here today
but i'm concerned a bit about the mixed
and heavy messaging coming from uh the
government uh the
unintended consequences of that can be
dire i noticed as my honourable friend
the chairman of the education select
committee the center for social justice
produced a report about the huge damage
to young children particularly in the
poorest communities when schools start
locking down and shutting them out can
you please ensure that the message is
clear to them that they are not to lock
down and secondly when i smoke this
morning to gps in my constituency i ask
them what is the one thing you would
like the second state to do now if
you've got to get all these people
through and they said do we really need
to have the 15-minute wait can we end
that and we would triple our way through
this and you would get it going straight
away so can you please act on that now
i mean first of all
mr deputy speaker can i very much agree
with my right honourable friend on uh
the importance of never losing sight of
unintended consequences he points to an
excellent report by the center of social
justice that looked at that from the
from the pastor actions that have been
taken and that is certainly not lost on
me on all my colleagues in government
but he's right to highlight that to the
house once again i hope he does agree
though with the measures that we've set
out so far they are uh they are they are
measured and they are proportionate and
the focus should be on the booster
campaign because that is our way out of
this on the 15 minute wait uh that the
my variable friend uh refers to um it is
being very actively looked at that
looked at and i will have something more
to say on that i'm sure very very
shortly barbara keeley
thank you mr deputy speaker
the syrian state says that there are
millions of tests available but only
nine local authorities out of 153 across
england have access to a float stock of
500 pcr test kits to use at their
discretion using local knowledge to
tackle covered clusters before they
become significant outbreaks this is
very important to disrupt outbreaks and
slow down transmission but it's not
available outside those nine pilot local
authorities given the importance of
slowing down transmission of the omicron
variant will the secretary of state
agree to authorize the same float stock
of 500 pcr test kits to every director
of public health and every area to give
them the tools they need to fight this
variant
mr deputy speaker can i say to the
honourable lady when i was trying to
test earlier it's the actual flow test i
think she's asking me about pcr tests
and i will look into what she said
esther mcveigh
thank you mr deputy speaker
last week's ofsted report was dabbing
about the impact lockdown has had on our
nation's children and the immense harm
if students have suffered with the
children's commissioner saying schools
shouldn't close again however it seems
that the government has left the door
open to school closures after the
christmas recess so can i ask what
specific conditions would need to be met
for schools not to open in the new year
mr speaker i i welcome the question for
my right honourable friend and what i
would say to her is that with the the
risk that we see from omicron at this
point in time with the rise infections
the increased risk of hospitalization
the information we have in the vaccines
we think we have taken uh the
appropriate responses a balanced and
measured set of response it is designed
to protect so much that we love in our
countries especially the interests of
our children but the most important
thing now to focus on is the booster
program
paula barker
thank you mr deputy speaker um and first
of all i'd like to say that i encourage
everybody to be vaccinated and also to
have the booster job and i'm delighted
that the secretary of state has moved
away from passport to having an lft test
if they can't show their covered pass
and i'd like to thank all from bench for
the work that they've done as well
my question is this secretary of state
you have talked about the incredible
work the nhs is doing and what it will
do over the next few weeks so will the
secretary of state pause
the plans he has for mandatory
vaccination of all nhs workers and have
the conversations with the trade unions
and come up with a plan for this to be
by consent rather than mandatory period
first mr deputy speaker um
yeah i agree with her with her objection
i think the lady had to vaccine passport
that would be a requirement for people
to be vaccinated to enter a venue a
high-risk venue i think it's important
that we focus on a test requirement with
an exemption if you happen uh to have
the the right level of vaccination
the in terms of her question on nhs uh
mandatory vaccination however um i am
afraid i have to tell we won't pause uh
what we have already announced uh not
least because uh and this is the view of
the nhs leadership as well not least
because omicron has made it even more
urgent that we continue with it
sir edward lee
four weeks ago i raised the matter of a
family member who is aged 90 completely
bed bound vulnerable at home
still no booster jab
i was promised action nothing has
happened he's still waiting and i
understand now that there are
potentially hundreds of thousands of
very old
very vulnerable people
trapped in their own home
still waiting for the booster job with
carers coming in and out all day
and yet we are now offering booster jabs
to 18 year olds who have virtually no
chance of falling seriously ill
this is an absurd situation caused by
massive delays bureaucracy and this
ridiculous rule that a doctor has to
come the nurses have to wait 20 minutes
with the old person all those virtually
a minuscule lit risk of there being any
harm so we need action this day these
people are in danger of dying will the
secretary of state now act on behalf of
very old people trapped in their own
my home friend is absolutely right to to
to raise this uh mr deputy speaker the
those that are either in in care homes
they're homebound uh though they have
been prioritized so for example i can
tell him uh with care homes i believe
that as of the end of november 97 of
care homes were visited by gps or other
primary care teams
to deliver vaccinations and in cases
where they couldn't be visited it's
because that care home itself had a
lockdown and they will all be revisited
again and again i know my honourable
friend has asked me particularly
specifically about people that are
homebound the same approach is being
taken and we were absolutely ensure
that every
single one of those people was as he
rightly says they are they are more
vulnerable than others uh they get the
visit and they get their boosted job
adam casa
thank you mr deputy speaker i had a busy
weekend on saturday i got my booster jag
from margaret a hard-working staff
member from nhs lanarkshire and i highly
encourage everyone to get dragged and
boosted then yesterday i met with my
honourable friend for east dumbarton
sure she is a hard-working and dedicated
member of less house and as an utter
shambles that she is unable to speak and
vote she is however doing a power of
work and her constituency is an absolute
inspiration for all of us
with the danger of listening ovarian
while the secretary of state agree that
less house should follow the lead of the
scottish parliament and move to virtual
or at least hybrid proceedings less
could protect vulnerable members their
families and set a positive example of
working from home
mr deputy speaker that is not a matter
for my department
mark harper
much um mr deputy speaker um you'll be
aware mr deputy speaker that a couple of
days ago the department of health
published some social media rather
jumping the gun on the decision the
house is being asked to take tomorrow
and very welcomed the secretary of state
intervened
and said no law is decided until
parliament votes on it and you arrange
for that graphic to be deleted now of
course that's not entirely true because
most covered laws have come into force
before parliaments voted on them
including the mass mandate however
the question i wanted to ask the
secretary of state is this the prime
minister refused three times this
morning
to rule out
further restrictions being taken before
christmas i'm not going to ask the
secretary of state to
contradict the prime minister at all but
what i am going to ask him is this
if the government does decide to
announce further restrictions before
christmas or indeed after christmas can
i have an assurance at the dispatch box
that this house will be recalled to
debate and vote on those measures it's
not acceptable to keep governing this
country by decree
you've got to involve members of the
house i agree with what the honourable
general said use members of parliament
which means involving us in the decision
getting this house to make the laws
and then you'll find there'll be much
more of a team approach to this rather
than decrees and late night
uh television addresses without taking
the house seriously
yeah yeah so
mr speaker first i'd say to my honorable
friend that there are there are no plans
uh that i am aware for any further uh
restrictions and what we are what we are
what we are focused on is uh what we i
mentioned to that i sent to this house
at this dispatch box last week that's
coming uh to vote and subject to the
will of the house we will see if those
become uh the regulations in terms of
his uh further question about an
assurance that is something i will take
back to my right or friend the prime
minister daisy cooper
thank you mr deputy speaker 18 weeks ago
on the 9th of august i asked the
government what assessment they had made
of using community pharmacies the
response in full
was that no assessment had been made
nine weeks ago 22nd of october i asked
the government if covert secure
transport would be available for the
clinically extremely vulnerable so they
could go to their booster job
appointments the government said it had
made no assessment
six weeks ago i asked the government for
guidance for the politically extremely
vulnerable i asked them to sort out the
problems and the confusion amongst third
primary doses and the booster jab and
two weeks ago on the same day that the
bmj published data saying that omicron
was more transmissible i asked the
government whether it would renew
contact racing funding for local
authorities a week later it said it was
still assessing it so my question mr
deputy speaker is will the secretary of
state apologize for the shocking levels
of complacency in rolling out the
booster program over the last four
months and will he now apologize to all
those patients who will have their
treatment cancelled as a result of these
new announcements secretary of state
no mr speaker uh mr deputy
i won't apologize for speeding up the
booster program uh to protect the health
of the british public
and uh and i won't apologize for asking
the nhs to make it a priority
if the honorable lady believes that we
should not be vaccinating people in this
country why doesn't she just say so
dr julian lewis thank you mr deputy
speaker it's been previously been
suggested more than once that when
deaths with covid are announced daily it
should simultaneously be stated how many
of them were of
unvaccinated people or of people with
underlying health conditions or other
specific vulnerabilities will he now
undertake to do that and did he notice
as i and no doubt others did that the
prime minister stated this morning that
one person in the uk had died
with omicron kovid but the shadow
secretary of state said it was as a
result of that virus does he know which
of those two versions is correct
the
mr deputy speaker my honorable friend is
is right to to point to the distinction
of uh
sadly those people that die either with
covid or of coba there is a difference
and i have uh come to this dispatch box
before to say it certainly with the
delta variant we don't have enough data
on omicron
yet for reasons i'm sure my own friend
will understand but with the delta
variant i'm told by the nhs that it's
approximately
20
of those people certainly in hospital uh
uh that uh that that have covered are
there because they happen to have kovid
versus those that are there because of
covet
chris bryant thank you mr deputy speaker
why are pcr
tests so expensive in the uk
why is the uk the second most expensive
place in the world to have a pcr test
why does the government website still
advertise pcr tests for 15 or 20 pounds
when they're not available anywhere in
the uk for 15 or 20 pounds why are they
still advertising pcr tests and um when
you go through the company concerned it
ends up being 50 60 70 80 120 150 pounds
for the test isn't there something we
can do to get the price of these costs
down because for a family going on
holiday at christmas or at new year you
could end up spending uh a thousand
fifteen hundred pounds just on the tests
mr deputy speaker the the ukhsa has
removed many providers or so-called
providers of pcr tests uh from the
listing and the government website
they've set a minimum price that must be
met so that to try and avoid uh
misleading prices unlike unlike some
other countries we have not chosen to
subsidize the cost of private pcr tests
because i think we have rightly
concentrated our resources on the pcr
tests that are available for people
domestically if they have symptoms
marie morris
thank you mr deputy speaker
the extended vaccine roller is welcome
to prevent infection but given this puts
even more pressure on resources what
steps has the government taken in tandem
to increase capacity in the nhs to
address increasing demand from both
covet and non-kobe patients i know that
the army has been brought in what about
nightingale hospitals might they be
reinstituted will we look again at the
pension challenge which stops people
senior people continuing to stay in the
profession will we look at accelerating
the training programs for our health
professionals as they have done in other
countries and will we create new health
professionals with shorter training
programs action is needed now to deal
with this capacity issue
my honourable friend of mississippi
because right to talk about the
importance of increasing capacity this
pandemic has has really acutely uh
brought that front of a front of mind
and there there has been a significant
investment ever since the pandemic
started particularly in certain types of
capacity especially icu capacity
capacity with with ppe with oxygen and
of course uh personnel uh as well with
uh some ten thousand nurses added over
the last years almost three thousand
doctors added and this is something now
because the only chronic emergency that
is being revisited about how we can
further increase temporary capacity
catherine mckinnon
thank you mr deputy speaker nhs data in
november showed that of pregnant women
in hospital with kovid 1998
were unvaccinated pregnant women want to
do the right thing to protect them and
their babies but there's been a lack of
clarity and a lack of prioritization for
vaccines for this group of people so
will the secretary of state set out what
the government is going to do to send
the message loud and clear
that vaccination uptake for pregnant
women and their babies is a priority for
this government
mr jefferson speaker it absolutely is
and the the work that's being led by uh
lucy chapel in particular in in my
department uh at the uk hsa this is one
of being one of her the central uh
focuses of of uh her work to encourage
more
pregnant women to to please come forward
and take up the offer the vaccine as the
honourable lady says
sadly when you look at the pregnant
women that are going into hospital
because of uh their covert infections uh
almost all of them uh are unvaccinated
thank you mr deputy speaker and can i
pay tribute to my right honourable
friend for the speed and efficiency in
which he the government and the nhs are
rolling out the booster program but does
he share my concern that the program is
being rolled out somewhat slower in
wales there is no access to walk-in
centers
there is no online booking system and
the local health boards are depending on
the royal mail when the postal system is
at its greatest pressure because of
christmas and because of uh
staff off with covid so will he agree to
share the expertise and capacity that
the uk government has built up in the
most positive way with the devolver
administration specifically with the
welsh government so that my conscious
constituents can receive the same access
as his constituents
yes mr deputy speaker i do very much
agree with that it's uh it's uk wide
this uh this uh omicron emergency is
ukraine wide and and all parts of the uk
should respond uh by increasing whatever
they are doing on the booster program by
increasing it further i think that uh
that the view is shared you know
certainly you know throughout the the uk
and we will also uh be providing more
support uh to to wales northern ireland
to scotland uh to make sure that they
can certainly increase their booster
program
greenwood thank you mr deputy speaker
testing and self-isolating are vitally
important in preventing transmission but
for people in precarious jobs who are
really struggling to make ends meet it
can be incredibly worrying and difficult
why is the government still not fixed
sick
so that everyone is properly supported
to do the right thing including those
people who may be worried about getting
their vaccination or booster due to
possible side effects and needing to
take time off work yeah
yeah mr speaker we of course uh keep
under review the support that is uh
available throughout this pandemic it's
important that
the house has decided to extend uh the
fact that sick pay can be available from
from day one and also there's a hardship
fund that is administered by local
authorities dr luke evans
thank you mr speaker and i can can i
commend to their health secretary for
bringing forward the booster and aiming
so high to get it out one of the key
things though is making sure we have
enough vaccinators and staff to be able
to do this as well as volunteers in that
vein we may ask the ics's all 42 of them
to review their bureaucracy around
signing people up to do vaccinations
potentially even to allow people from to
work from gp practices and into
hospitals and vice versa because
practically over the last year one of
the issues is people are turned away or
lose interest because of the bureaucracy
with regards to paperwork when it comes
to vaccinating given the challenge ahead
of us i'd be grateful if you consider
asking this approach
my honourable friend speaks with great
experience and he's right to talk of uh
how can the
the training program for vaccinators
especially volunteer vaccinators be
streamlined and that work is going on at
urgent speed uh both within the nhs
within the ics's uh but also uh the to
help further support the fantastic work
that john's ambulances been doing in
this space
thank you foxcroft
thank you mr deputy speaker i've asked
the secretary of state on numerous
occasions about antibody testing for
immunocompromised people his answer has
been antivirals when people get covered
right has he looked into giving
immunocompromised people antibody tests
so we have a clear picture of who will
need the antivirals quickly if they get
of
covert
mr deputy speaker my my understanding is
that
for the immuno compromised and
clinically extremely vulnerable that
antibody tests are available if that's
what their consultant believes is
necessary
dr
my interest as a vaccinator i support
the level of ambition that the secretary
of state has articulated but would he
distinguish being between being offered
a jab and actually getting the jab you
could be offered a hip replacement but
it doesn't mean to say again again
anytime soon
well first uh mr deputy speaker i want
to thank my honourable friend for for
being a vaccinator and and all the work
he's done to help personally to help the
country get through this pandemic and of
course there's a distinction he's
absolutely right there's a distinction
between
the nhs being able to offer an
individual a job so they might receive
an email or a text saying please come
forward either book or walk-in you're
eligible but it does take that
individual to come forward themselves uh
and and take up that offer and that is
why a huge amount of effort now even
more effort than before will go into
persuading people to come forward
derek twigg
thank you mr deputy speaker can i ask
the secretary of state why the
government has no coherent plan for
dealing with uh elective delays in
elective surgery and treatment and i say
this because i recently put down some
parliamentary questions uh and asked
about the impact they've got the the
recently announced government funding on
waiting times over the past three years
but what the secretary state said in his
answer was no estimates has been made uh
at this time i then asked about the
estimators being made about the private
sector capacity again no estimate has
been made so as the secretary states
what is the plan to deal with this huge
backlog
of elected treatments and just say to
him that macmillan estimated 50 000 uh
missing there are 50 000 missing cancer
diagnosis in the uk and 32 000 waiting
for the first cancer treatment in
england
mr deputy speaker may i remind the
honorable gentlemen the government has
already set out in terms of uh dealing
with the challenge around electives the
biggest catch-up fund for electives that
this country has ever seen there's an
extra 2 billion pounds of funding
provided in the second half of this year
8 billion pounds minimum provided over
the next three years and the nhs in
terms of a plan the nhs is working on a
detailed plan and that will be published
as soon as it's ready
thank you mr deputy speaker the health
sector should be very proud of our world
leading vaccination program and i join
the minister in sending out a message to
anyone that is anxious to come forward
and to get their vaccination this
morning breakfast telly was being
broadcast from backstage at gp surgery
in my constituency of wilden and there
was huge anxiety how the nhs staff were
going to cope with delivering the
vaccination i'm incredibly anxious about
the mandated
the mandate the man
i'm incredibly anxious about the si
about us mandating vaccines for nhs
staff because it means i believe 126 000
nhs staff will leave the sector is this
the right decision to take when nhs
staff are already saying they're working
all the hours god gives
us
mr deputy speaker we will debate that
aside here in the house and i'm happy to
talk more about it then but what i will
say to my honorable friend uh
i think the number she's referring to is
the number of people the nhs estimated
at the time the government said it was
going ahead this si that remained
unvaccinated i'm pleased to inform her
that since then it's a it's a smaller
number and tomorrow we will have the i
will come with the latest numbers that
we have it's improving all the time and
when we did a similar measure for the
residential
care home sector
we saw the number fall and fall of those
unvaccinated day by day as more and more
people had positive engagement and took
up the offer of a vaccine
rachel masko
thank you mr deputy speaker when the
transmission rate for omicron is twice
that of delta
when we are asking people to work from
home why are we then
saying to people that they can go out
and socialize in venues unmasked when
the data contact tracing data from last
december show that those social spaces
is where there is high levels of
transmission
secret mr deputy speaker it's about
having a balanced and proportionate
response
and and that is what the the the
government has done and uh it is about
recognizing that these restrictions uh
yes they they help to you know slow down
the rate of spread but they also have a
real impact on people's lives and it's
about being proportioned in that
approach
dear clark
thank you mr deputy speaker i welcome
the prime minister's announcement that
booster vaccines are to be offered to
all adults and i was grateful to receive
mine last week at staffordshire
georgia's hospital
but in order to defeat the new covert 19
variant we need to vaccinate as many
people as possible so can i urge the
sector of state to open a walk-in
vaccination center in stafford which we
currently do not have
well first uh mr deputy speaker can i
congratulate my animal friend on getting
boosted and secondly uh she may have
heard me earlier we're going to open
many more walk-ins and pop-in centers
and i've heard a representation so as
the vaccines minister and we will
certainly try and make that happen uh mr
deputy speaker if i may just uh in
response to a question earlier for my
honorable friend uh the member for uh
the moral friend member for winchester
he asked me about the vaccinations uh
proof uh that i announced earlier for uh
for children and uh i just want to make
it clear mr speaker that that will be
it's a you can order uh the proof online
but it will be in the form of a letter
but it could be ordered online the
digital pass access will come later
kim johnson
thank you mr deputy speaker the contain
outbreak management fund is a vital
resource used by local authorities
and directors of public health it's due
to end in march 2022 so can the
secretary of state confirm whether this
funding will continue beyond that date
and whether it will be increased to
support local authorities
mr deputy speaker it's an important fund
and i will look into that
maria miller
thank you mr deputy speaker and can i
thank my right honourable friend for
everything that he and his whole team
are doing in what are incredibly
challenging circumstances and can i
bring him specifically back to the issue
of access to boister to booster
appointments
he set out in his statement i felt an
indication that the the booster rollout
was now a national program rather than
being perhaps locally led now our local
gp's teams are doing a fantastic job but
will this difference in approach mean
that more pharmacists like the ones in
my town in beijing stoke will be able to
be part of the booster rollout in a way
that they haven't been able to to date
thank you so much yes uh first uh if i
can take to my right on my friend the
booster program the vaccination program
it's a national program but it is
locally delivered and she's right to
point to improving local delivery in her
own area by having more pharmacists
involved and i can actually give that
insurance part of our plan is to involve
hundreds of more pharmacies and the the
good news they're incredibly keen and
that's exactly what i expect to happen
and brad shaw can i thank him and his
vaccines minister for finally sorting
the problem of the under 18s being able
to access their uh proof of vaccination
and will he assure me that it'll be
operational in time for the end of the
school term this week but on travel more
generally he agreed with me last week
that once omicron became
widespread here that the very draconian
costly and complex travel rules he
introduced two weeks ago to stop omicron
coming coming but no longer would be
pointless uh to quote my words so why
are they still in place
mr deputy speaker
if i can say to the honourable gentleman
that first the um
on the under 18s the the proof of travel
for for the vaccination proof for travel
as i mentioned a moment ago uh that that
is available from today so it's
available you go the individual would go
online or the parent would go online and
request it it comes in the form of a
letter uh which is uh
something that's perfect acceptable to
all countries uh that we are aware of
that required uh the second uh issue
around uh the current travel uh
restrictions uh i think my honor would
the honourable general makes a very good
point uh given that we already know that
uh the uh the omicron variant is uh fast
becoming the dominant variant in our
capital city spreading rapidly
throughout the country uh the the
justification for hiring those rules i
think is minimized it is something that
i have already raised with my colleagues
in the department of transport and i do
hope that we can act quickly
mr gibson thank you mr deputy speaker
can i thank my right honourable friend
for the measures to enable travel in the
12 to 15 age group which is particularly
welcomed by the rear family in my
constituency who are traveling tomorrow
on what is possibly their last family
holiday together
can i ask my right honourable friend to
clarify if a person is currently
isolating today can they switch to daily
testing from tomorrow
and what plans does he have to extend
the opening hours of the walk-in
vaccination centers such as that at st
thomas's across the river which will
close at 8pm tonight
well first of all mr deputy speaker i
hope that the weir family will have many
more holidays no one wants to be there
last holiday as a family but i'm pleased
that they can go ahead with their plans
they'll be able to access that proof to
for their children uh today on the daily
contact testing i can confirm if you are
vaccinated so you have to be vaccinated
that if you are vaccinated and isolating
today that uh from tomorrow um subject
to the will of a house that so that they
that individuals uh can um go
remove move from isolation into uh daily
contact uh testing and in terms of uh
the opening hours uh certainly for all
the large vaccination centers they will
be increased the minimum will be 12
hours but many of them were going we'll
be going way beyond 12 hours
let's twist
thank you mr deputy speaker with the aim
to get such high numbers uh
having a booster through the booster
program by the end of the year how will
the secretary of state ensure
that there are inequalities generated by
the push for numbers rather than need
i'm thinking of those who may not be
able to
access digitally the various systems all
those in areas of health inequalities
so i'm going to say it's it's a very
important point the honourable lady
raises because need is is is more
important than the actual overall
numbers of course we want to see the
numbers increase but the focus should
always be on the most vulnerable uh
first and the way the nhs will ensure
that is the work that's being done
especially by the gps that can make home
band visits visits to care homes some of
the more vulnerable people in society is
that there will be an increased number
of those visits
andrew salud
isn't the lesson from this pandemic that
early and proportionate action
save lives ends up preserving more not
less of our freedoms and is actually
strongly supported by the silent
majority of the british people
my honorable friend mr deputy speaker is
is absolutely right and that is that is
exactly uh the purpose of the plans that
we have set out uh the the the measures
that we will be debating this house uh
tomorrow but also the the action that
we're taking on the booster program
which to get more people protected so
they can
enjoy their freedoms
stephen pennecock
thank you mr deputy speaker to my
frustration it was only immediately
prior to this statement i was able to
obtain a copy of the regulations we're
voting on tomorrow so could the
secretary of state uh
provide me with clarity when it comes to
mandatory covered passes in two respects
firstly will it be the case that an
individual can no longer
demonstrate their covert status on the
basis of natural immunity via pc a
positive pcr test when it comes to
accessing
these high-risk venues and secondly can
you reassure me for those who don't have
access to computers or smartphones they
still will be able to
apply for and obtain an nhs code pass
letter to uh obtain access to these
venues in mind
thank you mr deputy speaker
so
in terms of access to the high risk
events your night club or all the the
large uh events there will be two ways
the the main way will be the to to take
a a lateral flow test and get a negative
result and and that could that would
need to be registered through the nhs
website and the proof could be through
the past or it could be a text message
result for example uh the uh there will
be an exemption from that if someone is
double vaccinated
but also
the the proof of vaccination can also be
given through the letter process
ah thank you
my a constituent of mine has both
anaphylaxis and urticaria she's been
told she cannot be medically vaccinated
amidst all the talk about second doses
and third doses she cannot access even
her first dose what assurances can the
secret contingency give her regarding
access to non-invasive forms of
vaccination
it's a a very important question from my
uh honorable friend
the the rules around uh the need to be
vaccinated whether it's for passes or
otherwise of course they do not apply to
anyone that is medically exempt
there are many people have that have
received receive those exemption
certificates directly from their gps
that's the that's the best route some
individuals have called 111 and received
advice
if if i could be of direct assistance to
my honorable friend then of course i
will help
so
can i take the opportunity to thank the
nhs staff and volunteers at the
vaccination centers in my constituency
including the one at entry race course
and the one that
holy rosary where my wife and i had our
booster jabs in the last few days
and
in some communities in the liverpool
city region there is low
vaccine take up as there are indeed in
communities across the country the
secretary of state has told us many
times from the dispatch books and is
predecessored the same that nobody is
protected until everybody is protected
so we make sure that the resources go to
those areas of the country
where vaccine take up is low where
additional resources are needed so that
our public health directors and teams
and the nhs have everything they knew
need to protect everybody through the
vaccination program
yes mr deputy speaker i agree
wholeheartedly with the honourable
gentleman what he's just said there the
we've talked understandably a lot in
this house over the last hour or so
about the importance of the booster
program but it is still hugely important
that we continue to focus on those that
currently remain unvaccinated
mr deputy speaker i welcome the news
that a daily lateral flow test will
replace self-isolation for those in
contact with the kovi case
welcome the extension of the travel pass
to 12 to 15 year olds and especially the
health secretary confirming that a
lateral flow test is the clear
alternative to being jabbed for access
to any venue and any event so there is
no reason for anyone to contact us
asking us to vote against a quote
vaccine passport unquote but what would
my right honourable friend say to those
who've had coveted recently been told by
the nhs they shouldn't have a pcr test
for three months and they need to travel
abroad for work purposes what should
they say when asked for proof of a
negative pcr test
first of all can i very much agree with
my honourable friend with his his uh
first set of remarks that the the the
the how this house is not being
presented with a vaccine passport that
is not on the on the table is not in any
regulation uh i don't even know where
that particular idea has come from uh
what the the government has been
absolutely clear about when it talks
about access uh to nightclubs or or to a
large gatherings of very large
gatherings so very targeted events
that the requirement is to take a free a
free lateral flow test and make sure
it's negative and if you don't want to
do that then you can prove your vaccine
status it's up to that individual that's
what it is that is not a vaccine
passport and the sooner we get rid of
this misleading description of what the
government is proposing uh the better uh
on on the question that my honorable
friend
has asked about i i do want to make sure
i get the answer to that right so if he
allows me i want to look into that and
get back directly to him
just matters thank you mr deputy speaker
my constituent lexi is seven years old
she has heart and lung conditions which
mean that she's clinically extremely
vulnerable and has been home-schooled
since the start of the pandemic her
parents are understandably desperate for
her to get vaccinated and get back into
school i understand it's the jcpi's
decision as to when this will actually
take place but can the secretary of
state give us some ideas to what
information jcvr are waiting for when
they're likely to make a decision and
whether he's doing everything in his
power to hurry them up to make the
decision that lexi's parents so
desperately need
mr deputy speaker i do understand the
the situation that the honourable
gentleman has described and there'll be
others across the country in similar
situations we do understand the
importance of this uh the the the jcbi
he's referred to is is looking at this
issue which i've confirmed earlier but i
will say to the honorable gentleman that
we before we can deploy any vaccine in
any particular age group it needs to be
approved by our independent regulator
the mhra is safe and effective at this
point in time we don't have that
approval the mhra are actively looking
at this but those are the the two things
that are crucial before ministers can
make a decision
you mr deputy speaker i too i had my
booster vaccine last week it was easy
and i had five different options near me
but that was here in london and that was
after weeks of unsuccessfully trying in
bath
to find anything near me or anything
that was convenient with the times that
i had available and that is the
experience of all my constituents in
baths so when will we have services that
are available here in london matching
those in constituents like mine in bath